when movie theaters reopen it's gonna be
very awkward to go to Universal CityWalk
an attendee AMC movie theater over there
boy the tension sure will be palpable
and the other thing too I can't wait for
the pandemic to be over so I can finally
get a haircut this is why we're a beanie
er I have a pony tail in every single
video now so apparently AMC no longer
wants to play Universal Pictures movies
at the feeders at their theaters I
remember a time so long ago when AMC
stubs a list program was testing in the
world $19.99 a month and then I could
rack up rewards points sometimes get $5
off my popcorn sometimes get $10 rewards
get some mozzarella sticks on top of
that ah watch The Invisible Man through
a list which is a universal picture
company we don't get screen exam anywho
let's break down this report from The
Hollywood Reporter this is what NBC
Universal is Jeff shell CEO said to The
Wall Street Journal the results for
Charles world tour have exceeded our
expectations and demonstrated the
viability of P VOD as soon as theatres
reopened we expect to release movies on
both formats because trolls world tour
made a crap ton of money estimated 100
million dollars video on-demand and in a
strongly worded letter to Universal film
Entertainment Group Chairman Donna
Langley AMC theater chair CEO Adam Eretz
as Shell's comments were unacceptable
AMC is the largest circuit in the world
and here's what AMC's Aronson disappoint
it was just comments as to universals
you know that rule actions and
intentions have left us with no choice
therefore effective immediately AMC will
no longer play any Universal movies and
any more theaters in the United States
Europe or the Middle East we don't know
how to handle the pandemic situation in
my ego is really faltering all over the
place right now this policy affects any
and all Universal movies birthday goes
today and as our theaters reopen and
it's not some hollow were ill consider
threatened no no no no no it's deadly
this policy is not aimed solely at
Universal out of pique pique now or to
be pontiff punitive yeah whatever
in any way it also extends to any movie
maker who unilaterally abandons Korea
when do we practices absent good-faith
negotiations between us so that they as
distributor and we as exhibitor both
benefit and neither are heard from such
agents currently with the press comma
today Universal is the only studio
contemplating a wholesale change in the
status quo hence this immediate
communication in response and here's
what the universal guy said we
absolutely believe in the theatrical
experience and I've made no statement to
the contrary as we stated earlier going
forward we expect to release future
films directly to theaters as well as on
P VOD when that distribution outlet
makes sense we look forward to having
additional private conversations with
our exhibition partners but are
disappointed by this seemingly
coordinated attempt from AMC and Nadeau
to confuse their position interactions
goodness gracious our goal then
releasing trolls world tour on P VOD was
to deliver entertainment to people who
are sheltering at home well movie
theatres or other forms of entertainment
unavailable businesses yes response to
the film we believe we made the right
move
and then here's where this is fun AMC
has been particularly hard-hit because
of its debt loading heading into the
pandemic following the closure of all
AMC locations in the latter half of
March Wall Street analysts worded here
that the circuit would be forced to file
for chapter 11 bankruptcy but grew more
bullish company view offering earlier
this month
Aaron himself is among the corporate
staff for load because of the closures
and the last thing will quote from here
universes you that really pronounced was
in this issue or impalpable of us so as
I drew the case aims you sit down with
Universal will discuss different windows
strategies and different economic models
between your company and ours however if
the absent such discussions
Oh conclusion there to our decades
incredible suggests what business is to
be together has sadly come to an end so
sad so this means f9 will not be playing
at the theaters Halloween kills will not
be playing at the theaters Jurassic
world
yeah Jurassic world 3 will not vote
AMC's the biggest one the biggest chain
worldwide
you know Cinna marks opening in July my
hat's true I still feel like this is
some type of public I don't care what he
says better not being a threat it's
clearly a threat I feel like there's a
desperate attempt here to prevent the
video on-demand experience from
occurring we're living in an
unprecedented time right now the movie
theater experience is gonna change it
undoubtedly will with the experience of
P VOD I can see what the NBCUniversal
CEO is talking about I think some movies
will decide to ultimately go to P VOD
and some will remain in theaters because
yeah I don't want to watch Tennant on
the small screen I don't wanna watch
Batman on the small screen I don't want
to watch f9 on the small you know oh
there are movies I definitely want to
see on the big screen I don't see though
how AMC could possibly get out of this
five hundred million dollar debt by not
allowing three what will ultimately be
juggernaut at the box office you know
like those three films I listed will be
huge films there not to mention all the
other Universal profit I mean there's
like Candy Man as well that's coming out
a lot of the Blum House movies they
partner with Universal primarily to
distribute their films I don't think
this was the right approach
I feel like this is now gonna turn into
the remember the spider-man deal that
occurred in Sony and Marvel and I like
what can they do with spider-man it was
obviously public negotiations and now
that's what they've entered into is
public negotiations I feel like a lot of
people will not mind the P VOD
experience there are people like us who
are probably watching this video who are
gonna want the theaters obviously like
undoubtably
when you have factor in the world I
think a lot of people will not give two
shits about having to watch a movie no
matter how big of a spectacle the film
is I mean maybe it'll be preferable but
I think they will not mind watching it
at home John thoughts yeah I mean
with this I think it's a little awkward
the way they're all dealing with it and
I do understand at least from AMC's
perspective the idea that it would have
at least been nice to talk about this
because we can talk remotely it's not
that hard from their point of view I get
it if every other you know major studio
has kind of been above the board about
it however I don't think they're really
in a power position to say that and have
Universal be like oh goodness
let us reconsider I don't know we'll see
I mean I think this is kind of
inevitable now especially because of the
pandemic and I have two questions based
on that one is to universal you know
partly I imagine you're seeing such a
huge success because it's the only way
to see this movie and people are hungry
for a new movie and it was just about to
come out and they had all that
advertising so now I wonder if this just
became their paradigm how that would
persist over time I don't see this as
being the downfall of movie theaters but
I imagine this would be a redistribution
because I got a think that a lot of
studios are gonna want to do this kind
of thing do a simultaneous release and
then you're gonna see some of the people
who prefer to stay home who hate going
to the theaters staying at home or you
know stacking up and saving that money
but you're still gonna have the people
who care about theater experience I want
to share that with their families in the
case of trolls too but you know I mean
say with you all about kids at the
theaters I don't necessarily think this
is the end of this conversation just cuz
it just popped off and it's such a harsh
light to extremes kind of debate no I
think it's kind of funny and yeah I get
universal entirely being like oh this
was a success we're just gonna kind of
duel release them from here on out
because that's smart AMC needs to look
at the world around them and especially
I think to this might have something to
do with the fact that they are doing
their own P VOD type stuff through their
app and things like that or at least if
not you like up-to-date pvo do you like
recent releases on demand whatever the
other types of VOD are there at least
three I can't imagine this as the end of
this basically and I wonder how AMC's
gonna persist and if they do file for
chapter 11 and restructure their whole
business what's that gonna look like I
don't think this will be the same as it
was though coming out of this and I
really wonder if they're gonna tear down
that theater AMC is desperate right now
as I'm sure a lot of MU
theaters are even like the local small
movie theaters especially yeah but AMC
beam the biggest movie theater chain in
the world they're desperate to make sure
that people are still going to the movie
theaters and I mean in some ways this
might work to their benefit cuz it's
obviously gonna open a door where
they're gonna it's not like they're
gonna Universal is gonna be like screw
you guys fine no they're gonna open the
door because at the end of the day we
don't know when movie theaters reopen we
don't truly know what will happen cuz
Universal might see that well actually
going back to the movie theaters we'd
make more money yeah yeah and at the end
of the day what they're always gonna be
looking for is how they can make the
most money possible I can get that AMC
is trying to make sure that they're
making the most profit possible getting
the most customers people attending
their theaters but if half of the
audience for a universal film is like
now just watch at home instead but
Universal also like coming out and
saying that they're gonna do this for
all their movies the universal hasn't
said yeah f9 and Halloween kills well
half of it I mean you could either watch
it on video in the math or if you go to
theaters well then I cool that's what
they're saying well that's a great point
too because now I'm starting to wonder
if you know you're gonna see the
approach warp tons of times and so maybe
they'll start having it where the first
two weeks it's exclusively in theatre so
you make sure that everyone buys a
ticket and doesn't you know stack up on
that twenty dollar fee movie is on
average go to streaming or rental or or
blu-ray within like a 90-day period
pretty fast yeah take like a year or
more and a big movie will have legs for
a while but most movies usually make
their biggest profits in the first two
weeks yeah and then other giant
blockbusters yeah take its place you
know undoubtably the system is gonna
change I don't know exactly what it will
be but AMC is looking rather what's that
hurt yes
looking feisty right alright guys well
what do you think of this news are you
excited to watch them slash no there's
some more leave your thoughts down below
subscribe click the notification bell
keep looking for more videos